it is just getting started so far he's
just giving his normal list of
grievances we don't consider that
necessarily newsworthy and there's a
cost to us as a news organization of
knowingly broadcasting untrue things wow
Rachel you're such a journalist you're
such a journalist you won't broadcast
untrue things now we know that the
vaccines work well enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated person Glenn
Greenwald who's an actual journalist an
independent journalist he tweeted this
he wrote the person talking about Maddow
who won a 30 million dollar a year
Comcast contract by telling liberals
Biden laptop was Russian disinformation
Lab leak was debunked Trump had secret
server with Alpha Bank Russia put
bounties on U.S soldiers says she's too
worried about the lies to show Trump's
speech